don't react challenge
14. we taking you back little throwback
mix let's go
vanessa bryant and lala anthony just
gave the don't react challenge on tick
tock a go
and let's just say they didn't exactly
nail it
both lala and vanessa shared the clip on
instagram tuesday
la la asking her followers quote who do
you think wins
a little throwback mix let's go here's
how the challenge works
whoever is participating has to listen
to some classic hits
without moving or reacting at all which
let's be real it's hard not to dance
when your jam comes on
anyway the besties gave it their best
sitting side by side smiling
but it didn't take long before the
catchy tunes worked their magic
okay so they kind of kept it together
for back to life and me myself and i
but when feels good came on it was game
over
cute right my advice get yourself a
bessie who will do a tick tock challenge
with you
[Music]
of course lala and vanessa are long time
pals
which lala echoed when e.t caught up
with her back in april
she opened up about how vanessa was
doing following the death of her husband
kobe bryant
and their 13-year-old daughter gianna i
talked to her every single day and just
you know continue to pray for her and
stay positive for her she i tell her
every day she's the strongest woman i
know
and um i'm really really proud of just
how she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there
you know as much as i can for her as a
friend she's just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing
no doubt vanessa is staying strong for
her and kobe's three daughters
17 year old natalia three-year-old
bianca
and one-year-old capri i mean doing as
expected
you know in in what what happened
obviously but
it's our job as friends and family to
just continue to uplift them and pray
for them and
definitely let everybody out there know
to to do the same they they feel it they
receive it and they're very appreciative